in Selma and now in a United Kingdom you
inhabit characters that give these
amazing powerful speeches that's
something that's in you obviously you
can you can do that you know yes I I
like to talk loudly yeah but you're very
commanding when you do that now I was
thing about this today if I had that
ability you know I've got kids I know
you've got kids I would use that at home
I would channel that ability at home to
try and make people this is the show
we're going to watch we're not gonna
watch if only it worked oh yeah I am
have you ever tried it ever tried to you
know what I have four kids and the
volume is so loud in my house generally
it's not until we go to a restaurant
that I realize just how loud my phone
past the show that's every day and
that's every day yeah I find the looks
or what I what work really well the
looks a good glare a good glare okay so
let's say I'm one of your kids I'm doing
something wrong and you're doing it
right now you're glaring at me and that
is pretty good that is very that is very
very good
less is more I find less is that's good
you do less is more my glare always
looks like I'm just not feeling well I
get a little bit of an overbite when I
glare and and you look a little
constipated as well yes that's because I
am
[Laughter]
you